were on the brink of a nuclear war
Lebanon could come in Syria could come
in Egypt already has 350,000 troops
staged to come in their threat turkey
CeCe is saying that he's going to come
in and if that happen Russia will almost
certainly come in and we could easily
Sleepwalk into World War III and you
know the United States the people are
running our government now Anthony
blinkin Jake Sullivan averil Haynes
Victoria Newan I don't think any of them
have a healthy fear of nuclear war we
also have a diminished Armory and you
know we're fighting a two-front war and
it's going to be tempting to go to the
you know to the punch line to the end
game